[Music]
ride through the city like I'm on a
mission to get it through the city like
BR if you ain't please don't and now
Brandon six
boy
sh good morning Los Angeles welcome to
gate
dla it is October 9th Monday morning
brisk Monday morning not going to lie to
you guys the weather out here is brisk
not going to sugarcoat it um yeah man
fresh off uh a nice little weekend with
the fam little my my little dude T
killed it in baseball three for three
three doubles six strikeouts he's like
Otani but half Mexican so that's
cool went to the
circus um we'll talk about that I'm
firing the kid circus has hurt my
feelings circus has hurt my feelings you
see that circus over off Tanga there's a
circus over off Tanga and uh why if you
wanted to take the fam there we do
pumpkin patches all day she's like the
circus I thought it was going to be like
a Halloween uh Vibe but it was just
straight up circus it's a family ran
family-owned circus like Brothers
cousins mom dad they're selling the
popcorn before you walk in they're
selling the tickets then they get in
there they're on motorcycles they're I
was just like man especially the
motorcycle it's like a it's like
a it's a like a it's it's hard to
describe it's like a ball it's a cage
and then these guys get in little
motorcycles and they're going like
around and around and there's a girl in
the middle oh and you're like I don't
know how they're going to do this and
then another dude comes out you're like
too and then you know when you're
watching porn you're like there's no way
that's going to fit and then another
you're like what another giant wiener
what another that's how this was it was
just I was like man you guys need to you
just need like stop this isn't worth the
money you like please stop it was so
nerve-wracking that the anxiety was
insane good show though good show kids
loved it good show good show we sat next
to Tory Spelling there yep Tory Spelling
was there she's she's super pretty and
person man like if you if you look at
like the TMZ and stuff like that she was
like homeless or whatever but now she's
kind of Hess she was like living at a
motel or something she went through a
divorce with the kiddos she walked down
like that's a pretty looking lady people
are hating on
her um outside that though man just
chilling just chilling fly to Sacramento
on Friday to pick up the the whip the
th000 horsepower at the crank it's
actually going to be around 1100 at the
crank uh TRX at Overkill so I fly up
there on Friday with the kiddo and uh
big J shops meeting us up there in the
film crew so it should be interesting
man but the first episode will drop soon
once we get that footage so excited for
you guys to see it can't wait to have my
truck back I'm missing it hardcore right
now super hardcore um let's get into the
fight game so you had some fights happen
over the
weekend by far the biggest uh takeaway
from the fight night all the not a bad
fight night not a bad fight night
they're competing with college football
so I'm curious on the viewership there
but uh Bobby green beating Grant Dawson
who's ranked number 10 was by far the
biggest surprise tonight especially in
33 seconds huge Underdog yeah Grant
Dawson I think won 10 in a row he's won
10 in a row undefeated in the UFC um
yeah look at that dude that's insane
yeah yeah uh but I mean including uh
outside the UFC he won one two three
four five six seven eight nine 10 11
fights in a row one draw and then fights
of vet and Bobby green who doesn't give
a flying crap about his wi streak and he
said oh you are you come from the D
white Contender series and you're the
Golden Boy check this out it's weird
because it wasn't like uh we've seen
harder
shots a lot of it is it's early so the
guys aren't conditioned so you'll see
some I bet he I bet uh Dawson could ate
that shot in the second or third round
or even later than the first when it's
early and you get hit like that
sometimes it takes a while to get the
body to recognize you're in a fist fight
so sometimes it can drop you if you're
not ready to go there uh tough one for
Dawson tough one he'll bounce back the
kids a Savage but uh Bobby green just
doing the damn thing Bobby Green's
always that guy in DC allude to it in
the broadc where he always gets there he
gets there and then he loses gets there
gets loses right so he's coming off a
pretty uh tasty little run here um the
Tony Ferguson win which you know it's
Tony got performance of the night and
they give him Grant Dawson he beatss him
so you're on a two-fight win streak here
Tony Ferguson obviously walking uh
zombie Legend and then Grant Dawson
young line who's won freaking 10 fights
in a row ranked number 10 in the world
beat him so uh a a great submission win
over Tony Ferguson and now a knockout
over uh you know a young lion he's
ranking number 10 Bobby green got some
more work to do got such a vet dude such
a vet Russ the card was whatever belor
um is it their last one I don't know if
their last last one but um if it is a
good way to go out uh Liz Carmo with the
leg kicks that fight was a little like a
daal Chris cyborg cat zingano um that
one was also weird right all dude all
these car all the fights on Bellator
felt a little weird not all of them but
the the main ones yeah you're talking
about the main card there just three
fights well the the main event didn't no
no no not the main okay that was that
was 100% but Cyborg and carmos it looked
weird think it just looks weird oh no
I'm not saying it was like set up but
you know Liz carou and oh liay McFarland
they're both homies right they're
friends they train together it just
looked weird I don't know it was I saw
the kick I saw the replay of the kick
it's but it was she was she was
investing leg kicks all night long so I
it just looked weird I don't know I
don't think it looked we I I don't think
it was weird I mean maybe the stoppage
the way you know but that those leg
kicks suck dude and the CG and G was
kind of the cyborg cat one the way she
kind of crumbled up there at the end
then was mad it was stopped and then
Chris went over to be cool and cat was
not
cool um
yeah again I don't think it's the last
Bellator like a lot of people out there
are saying they obviously have one
planned uh belor 301 and they even have
fights after that here's the thing with
with Bellator with pfl all this stuff
it's not good that Bellator is going
away you know they're up for sale and it
sounds like the pfl is going to buy with
all that Saudi money like I've alluded
to before on the show it's not good guys
this is not a good thing that bellator's
going away
um you just you as a young Fighter
coming up in the rankings same as as I
allude to last week too with boxing with
HB not having boxing Showtime not having
boxing espan still kind of in the game
but you have these one-offs it's not
good for the growth of the sport if
you're a young boxer if you're young mix
mixed martial artist having options is
the way to go before in boxing it's
completely different but in when you get
to the UFC you better be ready to go
well if all you have is LFA or local
shows to get ready for you're going to
see a lot more guys losing when they
come to the UFC the this the talent pool
is so heavy in the UFC there's so much
talent one through 80 in every weight
division it you don't want to learn how
to navigate the Waters of professional
sports getting to the professional level
so it's a bummer man it's a bummer it's
no different than NFL what screws them
is what when you're seeing these young
quarterbacks because of the contracts
and because they can get out of the deal
in two years or three years so you're
the teams are forced to play these
rookie quarterbacks who probably
shouldn't be playing right away because
in three years if they do well they can
just demand all the money so the team's
like all right well let's see what we
got instead of back in the day you see
like Aon Rogers who sat behind Brett VAR
you see guys that can sit learn the game
see the actual speed the development of
the offense and then come out and
perform but now it's like be better be
ready to go better go from University of
Alabama University of Colorado straight
to the freaking starting for the Miami
Dolphins Denver Nugget Denver Broncos um
greenb Packers it's like there's no
there's there's no lead time now you
have to perform right away it's not not
good it's not the way professional
sports should work there's those
outliers who can get it done but as far
as the growth of all professional sports
you need these feeder leagues you need
these other leagues like the Bellator
like the pfls uh like the strike forces
of the world um you know you have one
Championship who competes with the UFC
but they're so big International they're
so big in Asia so you have what one
championship of UFC that's it and so
those Bellator were great for guys also
as far as negoti ating negotiating going
belor is going to me this pfl's going to
give me this UFC going give me this so
he can p them against each other you
want competition so it's not good for
the game that belor is going away it's
not good for the game if pfl doesn't get
bigger you know so right now you just
have one Championship UFC it's not good
for Fighters and there's a lot of
Fighters out there so we'll see man it's
it's also I think this is and this is
part of the problem and we're going to
you know get to it with Logan Paul and
Dylan danis and you have the Jake Paul's
of the world and ksis and the Tommy Fury
who's now into you know the influencer
boxing stuff
but part of the reason why they're so
big and because there's a lane in
fighting for these YouTubers like the
Logan Paul and Jake Paul's of the world
is because of the bad business by these
other leagues so you have the Nate
Diaz's who spent their entire body of
work in a big promotion like UFC they're
Legends they they've become these
mythical cre creatures but they can't
ride off in the sunset so they look for
a a Dylan danis fight a Logan Paul fight
a Jake Paul fight so they can get their
nuts so they can get these big paydays
the reason why that's so big now is
because the lack of pay the lack of
leadership the lack of structure as far
as the UFC pfl one Championship goes
that's why these things are um become as
successful and become as big as they are
and the young kids are tuning in to the
Logan Pauls and the Jake Pauls of the
world and they're going to tune in to
Logan Paul and Dylan danis and think
that's the same as a Canelo vers Charlo
fight that's what we're dealing with I'm
not saying it's a bad thing where's a
bad thing is because you're getting this
new Young audience tuning into fighting
which all good as long as tune in
fighting that's all I care about but
it's not the same as a Canelo fight it's
not the same as a Izzy fight Sean
Strickland you're not getting the
highest level of competition you're not
getting Elite athletes competing uh and
you're paying for it so it's a
double-edged sword because also with
these kids tuning into it what Logan
Paul and Jake Paul and KSI have done to
the fight game now is flipped it on its
head
because Logan Paul suing Dylan
danis before their fight sets a horrible
standard saying his girl so just yeah
I'm sure he has I I know you're saying
but yeah technically it's it it's his
team it's it's Logan is behind it so his
girl suing there's a season assist the
issue with that is that opens up a world
of issues for Fighters because now I
don't know who would do it in the UFC
and be taken serious but now it imagine
if Conor McGregor imagine if khabib sued
each other before the fight you what
what are we do what imagine if Sean
Strickland say some wild stuff imagine
if he get sued imagine if Bryce Mitchell
whoever he fights next they want to sue
him over you know fake information I'm
not saying what he's saying is fake I'm
just saying there could be a road to
that so it's good that Logan and Jacob
bring all these eyeballs it's bad that
some of the lanes that they're going
down es and not necessarily Jake with
Logan who buddy I'll be straight up
onest Logan who I do support love Dylan
Dennis too
um it I the first rule of Fight Club is
we don't Sue each
other the first rule of Fight Club is we
don't Sue each other and we know granted
maybe crossed the line but we know it's
actually going to equal more pay at the
end of the day and more eyeballs going
into the fight because if you're Dylan
dannis and you get the Logan Paul fight
and you're sitting around with your
management going how are we going to
sell this fight well we can't sell this
fight off what he did in the Floyd
Mayweather fight he lost that fight we
can't say you know technical wise
technically his boxing his footwork we
can't really do that can't allude to the
KSI fight can't go to the other YouTuber
they lost to so we can't knock his
fighting skills there's not much there's
not much meat on the bone there so what
else can we do all right well we're in
this YouTube World we're gonna have to
make it personal okay well can go for
his you know the how you kind of screwed
people over with the what was it bit the
Bitcoin or crypto stuff you can go down
that but that gets hairy and it gets in
the murky in the waters and the the
common fan who's not balls deep into
Logan Paul doesn't know what you're
talking about that's not going to work
what else can we do well we can go to
the Japanese 4 suicide thing that's old
news we've moved on from that what else
can we
do uh go for his
girl all right there might be something
with that she's a public figure okay
might be something with that apparently
slept with a lot of guys okay might be
something to that so in order to sell
the fight Dylan did exactly what he was
supposed to do and now you getting sued
for
it and
who my question with this is
who has the majority the the shares of
this fight who's going to benefit the
most off this fight being bought LAN
Paul y Dylan danis doesn't according to
his face off doesn't have a a portion of
the pay-per-view sales he's getting a
flat fee he does not get a portion of
the sales he might have said that
flagrant but he he doesn't get a
pay-per-view percentage he gets a flat
fee so either more to it that's only
helps Logan because whether you hate
Logan so you're tun to watch him lose or
you hate Dylan danis you're tuning to
watch them lose or maybe you you just
you're kind of in the middle on both of
them but you're tuning in because you've
seen this bad blood you've seen this bad
blood not because of Logan because Dylan
danis Logan's fans are going to tune in
no matter what he could be playing
freaking pickle ball and still get the
same views they just decided to go on
this crazy Road of fight fighting which
is insane more kudos to them but I just
again I don't know how far it goes what
Dylan did and some of the stuff that he
did what I do know is the first rule of
Fight Club is you don't Sue each other
you don't Sue each other you don't talk
about practice that's just what we do
so outside of this let's say they
weren't fighting and Dylan was doing
this okay now I see defamation he's
going after your girl your fiance that
makes
sense that's fine but if as soon as you
sign the contract to fight you make him
pay with your fist not with your lawyers
not with your money through your fist
that's why you're fighting now all your
theal Paul fans can't stand Dylan for
doing this now you get to watch the guy
that you love punch the other guy in the
face dimn the rules that's how this goes
Nobody wins when you sue nobody a judge
might say this guy wins you both lose
when parents get divorced they bring in
lawyers everybody loses mom loses dad
loses the kids definitely
lose because all the only people that
make money the only people that win in a
in a court case are the lawyers they're
both getting money money the defense and
the prosecution they're all getting
money the only people that don't make
money are the actual victims of this so
for
Logan again I I'd have to talk to Logan
I don't know at what extent this goes to
where Dylan you know obviously he had
had some he have some horrible video or
whatever um I don't know what's going on
he didn't post that thank God you know I
don't like that they're going down this
road in any facet all I'm saying is I
sympathize with Dylan if I'm going to
sell a fight I can't go based off his
fighting credentials so what else are we
going to do to sell this thing what else
are we going to do to get people to tune
in we're going to go for his personal
life we're going to go for his fiance
who is a public figure who is very
famous and then Logan goes I don't like
that I'm suing you well now I'm not as
interested in the fight if you hate that
beat him
up you know people I wish I could just
beat up and then make money to do it
that's how you win dude by punch him in
the face not by hurting his pockets
that's what I don't like no matter what
he did you setting this standard that
it's okay to sue another fighter in
hyping up a fight sets a horrible
standard especially for these younger
viewers who go oh man if you cross the
line again you might get sued now
Logan's the bigger dog here has all the
money in the world and that's how these
lawsuits work he's gonna keep coming at
them his girl has a ton of money keep
coming at him and Jake Paul said on I
think it was his podcast where had Logan
on he goes you know I've done my
research I'd estimate Dylan has $60,000
completely off he's way off you didn't
do your research bud you didn't he has a
lot more money in that that even that
being said again we're going down a
dangerous road when it's about this guy
has more money so he's going to sue this
guy but you've already agreed to fight
each other so what you're doing is all
this buildup with all this
frustration the fans aren't like yeah
Sue him and take his money that's how
that's gonna be make us so happy nobody
even Logan Paul fans are like no we
don't like that no no punch him in the
face that's what we want first rule
fight clubs you don't Sue each other if
you've agreed to fight each other you
just don't man dim the rules since day
one dim the rules can you imagine if
this was the the norm and Mike Tyson was
getting when Mike Tyson was young he
said some wild [__] I'm going to eat
your
children I'm Gonna Make You Love Me I'm
gonna [__] you too you love something
like that yeah hey language oh sorry my
my we're live man come on dude the point
is he said some crazy stuff we all know
that one but you screwed us um but
imagine if he got sued yeah you like
this is what are we doing here man what
are we
doing imagine if your favorite NFL team
sued the other team because they said
stuff they don't
what in the
contract whether it's UFC pfl one
Championship W wbco boxing whatever it
is in the country said you're not
allowed to sue in under any terms you
cannot sue if you've are both signed a
fight you can't sue I don't care how
personally he gets you can't sue now
after the fist fight if it continues do
your thing you're not under contract
with this do your thing so if this fight
happens Saturday let's say Dylan knocks
him out then posts that video and keeps
going with it okay Logan get his ass now
it's defamation out but if you've agreed
to fistf fight another man in a ring you
cannot
Sue that's just not what we do and I
didn't mean to rhyme there if the glove
don't fit you must have quit it's just
what you just can't it's it's just not
it doesn't make this fun for us anymore
it doesn't make it fun because
now Dylan
danis whether you think he's a win or
lose let's say he wins on
Saturday that purse is going to go to
lawyers who none of us like nobody likes
a lawyer they all suck Brilliant Minds
you need them sometimes but they're all
sharks dude all lawyers are [__]
sharks and they cost a ton of money
now when you're watching the fight
you're rooting for Dylan but what are
you rooting for well if he wins he
really doesn't win I guess he wins as
far as social media goes which we know
isn't real he wins and we go okay now
you know his person can go to fighting
Logan Paul in court and he's probably
gonna lose I would assume Logan has some
smart people around him they're not just
going to throw a seasoned assist whether
it's Logan or his girl they're not just
going to throw that out there and sue
him and have no case that's not he has
smart people around him so yeah Dylan
might win Saturday but eventually he's
going to lose who win online that
doesn't pay your bills and that sucks
this is actually hurting the views this
makes me less interested in the fight no
matter what he did it makes me less
interested in the fight it's a shame I
wish Logan didn't do this but again they
don't come from the same cut that most
and I don't want to say Logan's not a
real fire compared to the UFC guys
compared to the guys who come up from
the ranks offly he's different he didn't
walk through that fire we know this it's
like baseball rules we know this Logan
not come from that world so he didn't
even think about I'm gonna Sue this guy
his team's like yeah get him his team
doesn't come from the fight world yeah
that hell yeah that's the move little
does he know in the fight game we're all
going ah damn dude all right now we're
out the legit fight fans
now we're out we're out this not what we
do it's not what we do man in the fight
game we don't Sue each
other in the and now again fight happens
on Saturday somebody gets knocked out
this continues do your thing more power
to you but leading up to the fight now
we know that this man's going to be sued
and probably lose and if he wins his
purse his purse is guaranteed if he
shows well now it's a bummer here's the
other thing you got to think about and
Dylan danis has alluded to this I think
he talked about on Schultz Show he goes
why can't I choke him out notos goes
because the boxing match he goes okay
why can't I choke him out if you don't
think Dylan danis is crazy enough to
choke Logan Paul unconscious because he
knows he's going to lose in court and
lose all his money he has nothing to
lose if Dylan danis goes in there goes
all right I'm going to box him if for
whatever reason I can't land it's not
going well I'm going to choke him out
unconscious just
just for the hell of
it if you don't think Dylan danis is
capable of that you don't know Dylan
danis I could definitely see him doing
that 100% he does not play by your rules
neither does Logan so for you guys to
think that Saturday night's just gonna
be a boxing match I don't think it's
far-fetched to say Dylan's gonna do some
wild crap Saturday night where if it's
going south he's going to ankor lock
them choke him out and Logan security
they think they're going to be quick
enough again they're not and that's
going to go viral again Dylan's going to
win on Saturday night but he's going to
lose all of his money in court case and
I guarantee you he'll get sued for that
I don't think Dylan cares he's a wild
boy I text Dylan on uh I think Wednesday
or Thursday he did an episode with
schultzy on flagrant and he talks
about losing his best friend who is his
roommate talks about getting kicked out
of Marcelo Garcia's gym he talks about
all this stuff losing his dad turning
towards alcohol turn turning towards
drugs and getting through it going cold
turkey now he's sober dude it's like
that's the D that dude that's it we know
he's the ultimate Troll and that's what
Logan signed up for even though he's
suing him now we know he's the ultimate
troll but that side of Dylan oh that's
it so when people go oh you defend Dylan
I like Dylan I've seen that Dylan that I
like that guy the troll I don't take any
of that serious but if you sign up for a
fight for him that a fight to fight him
you of course that's what you're going
to get dude and he's going to do it by
any means necessary and you can't sue
them that's like buying a pit bull and
then being pissed that it's super
athletic and fast what you bought it
they take the dog park and it's freaking
out it's dog aggressive yeah man it came
from a different background it's not a
lab if you want a lab agree to fight a
lab if you find a pull don't be upset
when the Pitbull does pit bull [__] you
can't sue
them now after do your thing but before
the fight we can't sue even if you were
going to sue let us know after the fight
hey this went too far he's continued to
harass my fiance then I'm with you but
leading up to the fight dude this is
what you ask for
Logan so looking at his record Dylan he
hasn't fought since 2019 yet he's like
in the news like crazy he always is
that's his thing so that's what yeah
he's bringing that much eyeballs to the
table yeah that's thing this as far as
breaking this fight down like we would
in like a big fight like you know uh
like Fury Francis or you know
um makev Charles oera something this
gonna be tough man it's going to be
tough yeah I don't care who you are I
don't care who you are a tough one would
he base it off neither one of them have
fought in a hot second I Logan hasn't
fought in since how long since
Floyd yeah right it's both of them
haven't fought in over a thousand
days
what 2021 for Floyd maywe junee 2021 so
they both fought about the same so one
fought in June 2021 it's been a hot
second well the reason that's below that
CH is because one's an exhibition one's
a professional got
gotcha yeah so KSI 2019 and then Floyd
in 2021 2021 when was Dylan's last fight
2019 four years it's been a hot second
and two knee surgeries that's another
big thing
too at I mean if you're going to talk
about this fight you know get rid of all
the drama stuff like that get all rid of
all the YouTube stuff and just talk
about straight up fight science hair I
mean athletically Logan's a lot more
athletic yeah as far as legit
competition Dylan's way more qualified
you look at you know four-time world
champion Jiu-Jitsu as a brown belt uh
compete at Black Belt compete in ADCC
you know he's a lot more accomplished
he's been in there with Gordon Ryan Jake
Shield some Joe Lu luison he's been
there some
monsters um but just
Jiu-Jitsu he's never been known as a
striker he also has two wins via
submission Bellator it's high level
stuff man
um again it's it's this is tough to call
it's high level stuff he comes from a
more established martial arts background
with his Jiu-Jitsu competing Bellator
competing ADCC uh being a world champion
Jiu-Jitsu then you look at Logan he's
off obviously been in bigger
entertainment spectacles as far as you
know he did fight Floyd Mayweather who's
smaller boxer but that's a lot of
pressure uh then he does WWE which isn't
real but it's still uh an athletic event
he did really good and there's a lot of
eyeballs
um I mean you you tend to side towards
Logan on this
yeah right I would yeah yeah I find
myself rooting for Dylan a little bit
just because all the [__] he's been
through you see you know he he's sober
now um there's a good person in there
you
know who could call this fight though I
don't know I'm excited for it though are
you guys yeah I mean if you're putting
money on it you're putting it on Logan
right no cuz the odds go to the odds oh
okay Logan has to be at minus 300 -
400 hold on one sec now they did agree
if Dylan beats him he'll fight him in
MMA I think so 450 for Logan plus 330
for Dylan what's this Paul ver dance
preview who will win uh go
down so the Paul brothers are big dudes
and in a sloppy boxing match Logan size
will be his biggest asset Paul owns 1.5
reach one and a half inch reach
advantage over the short to danis that
doesn't matter at their level it matters
in Big Time
competition and this is odd Tio Paul is
a disaster his long strong arms will
help when he blasts upper well this
breakdown is
atrocious so they think because he has a
longer reach in tight quarters it's
going to matter but his technique vers
Mayo is atrocious more often than not
Paul saw red and swung his arms wildely
attacking a sheld up Mayweather with
awkward swiping punches they think
that's going to be different here okay
again again Paul is a larger man than
danis and he's fought more recently and
lives lives what I would assume is a far
healthier
lifestyle that's all yeah we don't know
neither do they yeah if I'm betting Paul
I do it by KO or
TKO the to reduce the chalk but we
may how to beat Dylan danis how to bet
Dylan danis if and a big if dannis
actually makes weight and shows up the
fight I think he will he's sunk the
20-year-old wants a professional fighter
it's two submission belt or S quality
grappling skills but when uh the ground
game is an option things get ugly as
Nate how he felt with heavy gloves and a
slug in front of them
H if you're betting danis drug test
yourself immediately okay this is weird
yeah but anyway the odds are the odds
are right here minus 450 for Logan Paul
yeah I mean it dude those odds at plus
330 is not terrible here's here the
thing neither one of them are great
boxers neither one of them are like you
know so at this level to bet on the dog
is not a terrible idea this breakdown so
[__] bad it's so bad excuse my
language it's so bad um they're just off
off clearly they're Logan Paul fans you
know but to bet on a guy in Dylan danis
who's plus 330 who has legit martial
arts background not terrible but strike
um punching though I don't
know
because Paul did last with Floyd I think
I think no matter if you take Logan or
Dylan it won't matter because Dylan's
gonna do something crazy and it's gonna
throw all this out the window that's my
prediction is Dylan isn't having success
on the feet and was like is just like F
this and chokes them out or at least
attempts to and security jumps in and
they stop the fight that's what I think
happens then you have KSI Tommy Paul
Tommy Fury who's not being talked about
at all which is crazy because because of
who Dylan danis he's getting
sued I don't see in any facet how KSI
wins that fight his build up for this
has been atrocious him doing this weird
like WWE like I'm gonna my soul I will
die
what
what yeah the other names I don't like
salt poppy slim Oh by Way Salt poy he's
a Philippine dud he's he's awesome to
watch he's a badass um he does YouTube
yeah he awesome to watch him he's like a
chubby he he knocks people out he gets
knock yeah he gets messed up too but
he's a fun a fun guy to watch King
Kenny Dean the great your T-Rex guy
T-Rex good for him against King Kenny
hell
yeah
interesting yeah these things are tough
to get into I you know it's tough I know
it's tough it's
tough It's it's very
tough I'm excited for it though
something to watch
definitely uh I
don't you can listen to me or you can
listen to that breakdown uh that I think
was on denone but for actual fight picks
I don't know if they're breaking this
down but I lean towards fantasy Guru uh
the NFL season popping don't bet on my
Broncos uh Shack uh you know don't bet
on Dallas Cowboys Niners Dolphins
Phillies probably Your Best Bets there
you have UFC Fight Night coming up and
then you have the magnitude of big
fights in the UFC coming up I'm I'm I'm
waving the White Flag make make these
picks is too tough so I partnered with
fancy Guru these are actual experts they
give real breakdowns help you with your
fancy football teams legit experts just
go to fancy guru.com that's fancy Guru
guru.com use the code sha for 20% off
that's fancy guru.com use the code shab
for 20% off for legit picks of NFL UFC
MLB got the playoffs popping right now
uh the Rangers are Texas Rangers are
kicking butt um I like Philly over
Atlanta hopefully Dodgers looked
atrocious um either way go to fancy
guru.com promo code is shop for 20%
off and also any show you listen to me
do you know I'm on that crom we talking
about happy Hipp it's the only katom
that I trust I got my Taffy here that is
the mocha Taffy some of my favorites
they got KPS first ever to Market Crum
KPS it's like the the the nicotine
pouches but filled with katum it's
fantastic there's winter green The
razzled Dazzle I think that fell on the
floor we got the katum energy shots 50
milligrams of highly concentrated uh
katum straight into your brain we got it
all powders gummies taffies pills what
however you want to get your Crum from
the best ever do it in the the business
use happy hippo go to happy hippo.com
promo code is thick 23 that's thick with
three C's you can use that as many times
you want share with a friend your Uber
driver your Postmates whoever you want
that's Happy hippo.com promo code is
thick with three three three C's 23
thick 23 three C's 20% off for
life all right so over the weekend also
was one Championship ton Lee who that
youngster too oh the youngster for sure
kid 16 he's 16 he wanton his W his fight
by
knockout I don't know if we can play it
or I'll just we can play okay
cool guess I have one contct before I
driver license iszy this
is 16 that's
insane and here's his knockout right
here
he's getting hit and then bam
boom Johan
gazali insane yeah Johan they call him
JoJo doing work and ton Lee he uh
submission heel hooked he trains with
Ryan Hall yeah and boom he got that
right away yep Mikey Mushi doing the
damn thing of course yep he had a little
bit of a weight issue too going in right
he didn't make weight the first time was
it Mikey or Mikey yeah oh I don't he was
sick yeah yeah he has something going on
with him and he always has like I always
see him with like a dark black eye I
don't know if that's part of his from
tapping ho out I don't know and TW tanai
who I was like huge on I really thought
I I I thought he lost that fight but
really he won with the judges yeah yeah
Mikey got it done again the legend of
Mikey continues pizza and Jiu-Jitsu
that's what weely good yeah Aoki just
you know I mean that's his thing too
grappling yeah I know but uh but that's
also Mikey's thing
yeah one Championship doing the damn
thing on Amazon Prime yeah it's so much
fun uh well this was there's a bunch of
different things that came out in the
headlines even though we talked about
Logan and Dylan so Dylan you know people
are saying that he's he's bailing from
the fight but then he's like no I'm just
joking Logan recently went on a podcast
with Jake Paul saying that he messed up
his wrist that broke his wrist like he
broke his wrist yeah like like recently
too Jake Al said he's only trading once
a week
yeah which anyway but they're both going
to be fighting apparently this weekend
so hopefully goes through yeah think
they fight I think they fight I think
there's some Shenanigans go on inside
that
ring it'll be fun I'm more excited to
watch it now to see if something
something does happen like that so Damon
Martin who's a very like legit you know
as legit as MMA journalist he did post
this uh a few days ago saying that uh as
of the last UFC usada update on SE
September 28 Conor McGregor hasn't been
tested for the you know for usada but uh
Dana White said that even though he
hasn't been tested it's not it's not
like all the way through yet but he did
submit paperwork so he's in the process
of getting into yeah just cuz you're
tested doesn't mean it starts then as
long as you're in the pool and they they
have the ability to test you that's when
it starts so he sounds like Conor's in
so he yeah at least the paperwork's in
so UFC 300 and Chandler just wait and
he's training every do you see his posts
on Instagram he's constantly Conor just
completely different know Connor's
partying challenge training but uh at
least the paperwork's going through so
I'll take it closer
yeah all right let's look
at this one was a little interesting so
this is uh shry saying that the UFC has
mediocre striking right and then Jon
Jones replied to that and we can play
this clip right if it's shot yes all
right let me uh refresh this real quick
let's say the UFC is very sloppy
mediocre is striking because they're not
Strikers you know you're a typical UFC
fighter is uh a D1 college wrestler s
and0 in you know the minor leagues and
then they they do a little bit of
striking and then they enter the UFC and
one all these are world champions before
they arrive and they already multiple
world champions at their peak of their
career when they arrive if you look at
our roster I think UFC has about 700
athletes tot we since there's music the
background I'm a little worried so
anyways he's saying that you you got the
point pretty much right yeah I don't
think uh as far as John saying stay in
your lane he is staying in his Lane
that's what makes them different in the
UFC all he's saying is we're different
yeah the UFC they get these D1 wrestlers
and they toss them in the UFC and they
develop striking we get world class
Strikers right off the bat and then they
develop into MMA fighters that's how
we're different he's not lying they have
more World Champion Strikers than the
UFC that's what makes it different
that's all he's saying stay in your lane
CH is going yeah no we are we are yeah
what I'm saying is that's exactly what
we're doing we're going to keep signing
world class Strikers while the UFC is
signing division one wrestlers and guys
you know who are not the best strikers
in the world and they develop them into
stars but what we do is different we
look for these world class Strikers
develop them in one Championship into
mixed martial artist yeah and also they
have the you know Muay Thai kickboxing
offer just striking Tha so it's stay in
your lane he's like that's exactly what
I'm saying that's how we're different
and that last card was insane the
product I don't think it makes him sound
like a hater then John gets on and goes
bro this doesn't make anybody want to
watch your show anymore I disagree uh
you just sound like a hater winners
focus on winning losers focus on
winners uh stay in your lane and do the
best you can without the UFC there would
be no one yeah yeah yes and no I I I I
don't think I think this is exactly what
John's saying he's staying in his Lane
going this is how we're different this
is how we're staying in our lane we look
for this the UFC looks for that they do
it well we do it Well everybody's
winning here again the better one
Championship does the better for UFC
fighters yeah the better UFC does the
better for one Championship the there's
not this world where they can't
coexist yeah I yeah competition's
definitely better for
everyone but Chachi is not say anything
out of line here say the UFC has very
sloppy mediocre striking yeah certain
level yeah some yeah some some know like
Izzy's ridiculous right Strickland's
ridiculous Francis was crazy overing one
of the best strikers that ever compete
inside of [__] cage yeah so they they
they do have some world champions but to
chat's point there's a lot of guys that
don't have world class striking who are
in the top
five that's fine it's just different
when championship does something
different UFC does something different
they're both crushing it I don't think
it's hating I think you're just poting
out what makes them different
yeah uh speaking of Jon Jones this is
interesting this is from Freak MMA I
guess uh Jon Jones and Paula Costa both
of them in 2023 have been tested at
combined 54 times by
usada which is that if those two what is
that crazy yeah 54 times is kind of but
I mean of all people since John did yeah
hell yeah Costa did mess up with like an
IV or something too so yeah that's good
here's what's interesting about Costa
and you know he's fighting hamzo pretty
soon here end of October October 23rd in
Abu Dhabi is it 21st the Saturday right
um he just announced he had surgery like
two two weeks ago three weeks ago on his
elbow for staff which not the end of the
world it's not like Li ligament damage
where he's be compromised and have one
arm but the note there should be that
when you do have surgery for if the
staff is that bad they got to cut it out
that means it's awful that means you're
on antibiotics which zap your cardio
destroy your card so there's no training
you can train but it's gonna be a
nightmare you've seen guys you know um
like haod Gracie remember fought the UFC
were like what's wrong with them he was
on antibiotics antibiotics zap your
cardio worse than anything you'd rather
have the flu you'd rather have coid than
fight with antibiotics so for him being
in there you that's at least a at least
a week off of trading and then you get
back to your antibiotics it's going to
be a problem and he needs all the help
he can get to beat hamide to you're
Twisted yeah him him without this it's
gonna be a tough task to beat hobza he
can definitely do it has a skill set to
do it it's a it's the old school vintage
Pao Costa who I'm a huge fan of but it's
a tough task to beat
hzza yeah uh this is a long video but
you do kind of he's bed up yeah but you
do you eventually see his elbow and you
see like a a ton of stitches right there
see it
yeah that looks pretty damn crazy yeah
it must have been really bad for them to
cut into it go in
there not the best news if you're a
apoll cost fan and you think he's gonna
beat Hamza and you want to bet on it
that's tough
yeah all right so this is what um is in
the headlines that so UFC is trying to
get morab Deval villy to fight uh Soo
said Henry SoDo say he's he already
signed or he's good to go but they're
waiting on morab but morab obviously
want to fight for the championship so
but Mor Rob's not going to the UFC is
not going award him that so this is the
next best thing moring F and if morab
beats cejudo which you know it's G to be
interesting if morab does beat cejudo
then there's no denying him a title shot
I love that without a doubt I mean even
right now like but
yeah and uh I think we announced this
before but so Kevin Kelvin gasin is
fighting Shawn Brady and uh Shawn
doesn't care if uh Kelvin misses weight
because Kelvin does sometimes Miss
weight he's like he'll just take 30% of
his purse he's cool with it I don't
think though he seems like he's on point
right now yeah so
yeah uh I just saw him when I was doing
shows in Arizona he was at your show
yeah he was awesome dude he looks good
yeah uh so drik Brunson remember he just
he's no longer with UFC they just cut
him like that and I thought it was them
releasing for him to fight Jake Paul
yeah yeah yeah but even in pfl he can
still do that so this isn't like just
because it's an out F Cooper pfl's part
of Jake Paul's
Camp so that could still happen yeah so
Derrick Brunson will Derrick Brunson
will be fighting Ray Cooper the third
which is a pretty tough fight too but
yeah that's gonna be cool Friday
November 24th
onf all right uh so Bobby green recently
was on that the same podcast the Jackson
with uh Rampage Jackson uhuh the Jackson
whatever jewelry place they do podcast
and then Bobby green said that he saw
videos of something about Islam makev
you know doing drugs like basically ped
and he he's accusing and where did he
see it I don't know he just said he saw
some videos I didn't see the proof of it
but he said khabib and uh Islam are both
on or were on stuff I I mean it's not
farfetched to think Russians would do
that stuff they have a pretty extensive
history of doing that but he said I
found this little video it said Islam
had a little trouble with drugs but I
don't don't see people talking about him
he was saying that when he first came
over the that his school that he trained
at in Russia they just gave him V
vitamins they've been doing this since
who knows when you start training may
you you give someone steroids from the
age 10 12 13 14 15 how strong you would
be or how how would mess up your growth
but people are like he was really strong
it makes sense now these two people that
I've moved around with I was like that's
interesting I've moved around with
thousands of guys that was that was
inter I told my coach there's something
interesting about Islam I felt it that's
just not human it makes sense yeah I I
mean we' need to see that video I yeah
and then this is
uh khabib responding to
him
lawsuit Logan's team's like sue him
um however this accusation King didn't
sit well notary retired UFC icon khabib
most fans know that the E is the mentor
of the current D stain lightweight champ
so what' he say I had he but basically
he said like uh it's just him putting in
the work he goes there's nothing wrong
with giving power to a champion with
whether you like it or not but it's not
given to everyone for this you need
brains preferably not from
straw okay I don't know it's the
translation is the tough part too yeah
with Bobby I I don't know if that's the
way to go I don't know what video you've
seen though but it's
tough and who knows maybe that video
show something and Bobby might think
it's real you know but it might not it
just maybe it's legit vitamins who knows
Russian vitamins uh so gamebr bare
knuckle he's he's going pretty hard he
has a bunch of different UFC Fighters
past UFC fighters on the next
card
uh obviously Al
Bel uh Randy Costa who used to be from
UFC as well Brandon
Davis Jason Knight Jason Knight pick
hick hick
Diaz and a bunch of others it's not
loading up though Curtis
millander of course Roy and this guy
Alex n Nicholson do you remember this
guy yeah I do he uh
he propo like proposed to his girl while
I was weighing in and then he fought
Misha sukov and then he got his jaw
broken it's tough at that fight he lost
a tough night in the office
yeah um I don't want to get into this
because it's kind of too much but let's
go oh so we talked about Alistar over
retiring he say he's going to retire but
now he's actually going
for he's going to run for office in
Dutch politics that's
cool oh damn House of Representatives
yeah I assume he wins because basically
a popularity
vote yeah we shall see I don't know his
politics oh he's lost so much weight why
is that politician bigger than over I'll
show you I'm going to play this oh is's
he on a box yeah you guess it I don't
want to play the music because it's like
the Rocky theme but uh yeah he's on the
box oh yeah yeah alist is tall as
hell so good for him uh your boy your
boy TJ Dillashaw because of his shoulder
looks like a villain from Marvel yeah so
he has to wait like another four weeks
or 6 weeks for it to heals and he's like
he can only do sponge baths so he's like
screw it it's too much trouble to wash
my hair so he shaved his whole head Ian
he looks pretty good doing it he looks
like a badass
yeah he's using some device it's like I
think what do you call that the postop
shoulder surgery full-blown shoulder
replacement damn stuck in this
Gunslinger brace it's like a c cartoon
and they had the cast with like the
broomstick holding up their arm that's
pretty much what I have going on but I
got to wear this thing for another four
weeks no showers just sponge bath in so
it was a pain in the butt to wash the
hair so I decided to cut it all off what
do you guys think he just sleeps like
this he does look pretty badass though
he does shaved head looks tough yeah it
looks good on him K needs to see this
yeah if you have a shaved head I think
you need to grow like you have to have a
bear you do style yeah you got to be
Dagan with
that all right um this is just a small
thing Jake Paul apparently is in this is
from Dave Meltzer so he's legit you know
yeah Dave is legit as kids so I guess
they're early talks with Matt riddle
because Matt Riddle's leaving iess Matt
Riddle's an interesting one Matt riddle
doesn't get talked about enough like
you're talking about a guy who had issue
with the UFC leaves yeah goes over and
wasn't a huge name in the no he wasn't
not at all he was on The Ultimate
Fighter leaves the UFC right has issues
with Dana and the way it was structured
leaves go to the WWE and becomes a
superstar in the WWE then leaves the
WWE and now he could possibly get a
fight with Jake Paul the guy doesn't get
enough
shine like there's very few guys who
leave the UFC and go on to have big
careers especially with not a huge name
no yeah no that's how talented that kid
is look at him Dy piece too dude let's
not get it twisted
here wow so he fought in Titan shout out
to Le 2014 I didn't know was that long
ago oh yeah it's been he's been in WWE
for a while because he was kind of newer
he's one of those victims of again you
better be ready to go when you get to
the UFC so for him you know it was a
learning curve there but then he just
dips out because I'm going do WWE
becomes a massive star in WWE gets way
more notoriety and fame from from WWE
bounces for WWE now he's talking about
Jake Paul
fight Jake Paul's like hell yeah dude
Matt Matt riddle it's a Hu and the
crossover obviously Logan Paul has the
WWE fan base so it's there Matt riddle
has the fan
base good on Matt Riddle Man hell yeah
do work young man shine on all right if
you seen the last UFC people started
bringing in fans again or sorry Flags
again and Daniel white said like it's
over the ban on flag Who start the the
fighters fighters yeah Fighters did they
really yeah I saw I think at least at
least one flag for sure but uh yeah so
you know there's a ban for a while
because of the whole Ukraine Russia
thing but now Dan Dan wat's like screw
this I don't care get a lot of flags I
saw someone on Instagram goes what if
someone brings out a flag says power
slap League sucks is he gonna be cool
with that yeah that's cool yeah so
that's cool they're
back um
oh so I don't know this is a small one
but Charlo versus Canelo is supposed to
be like the third highest pay-per-view
what's the highest it was like 750,000
that that's not bad that's all Canelo
that's that's how big he is oh so behind
javante Davis versus Ryan Garcia and
Jake Paul versus Tommy Fury Jake Paul
Tommy Fury them is that
dude good for them
wow tank Ryan Garcia number one though I
assume yeah yeah yeah makes sense
uh another quick one Jake Shields
remember he had a a scuffle with uh Mike
Jackson at the pi so he is there's a
warrant issue off for his R Us right now
again why don't they just fight first
rule of Fight Club you don't Sue dude if
if if if if it's possible that you can
fight each other and you both have
backgrounds to mixed martial arts you
don't Sue dude I know you fight each
other that's how this it's old school
man forget the lawyers forget who has
the best laer fight each other
physically hurt each other not and end
it financially yeah just fight and then
shake hands like Fighters do hug each
other with good fight man move on this
is
stupid what else you got um this is the
last one I just saw this man Fury got
some
love you know how most you know how like
uh only fan girls all the weight goes to
their ass and titties for FR for Fury
goes straight to his handles and like
one's this one's like oh I don't know
and he has he has some nipples on him
too yeah man he has some tits it's just
like what he's wearing is just such a
trip to me I don't know anyway R said
but why y'all put him in a tank top
though why did they put him in tank top
put him a baggy black shirt man and it's
so tight it's like so tight it's a
disaster still the most skilled box on
the planet with that body shout out to
him um dude did you see the trailer for
Francis Fury oh it's good yeah it's good
o it's tasty best fight promo in how
long I don't know price since a McGregor
fight like a big McGregor fight buildup
the the the khabib Connor buildup was
fantastic the fury Francis one oh it's
good yeah I don't think we can play it
I'm scared yeah but yeah we'll get
banned but yeah but it's pretty it's so
well done highly produced well done you
can find it online anywhere you if
you're alive you can find it
uh yeah so that's pretty much it dude is
that it we've got a you got a fight a a
bad fight night let's just call it what
it
is the Logan Paul Dylan danis fight's
gonna get more views than this it's so
funny you say Logan Paul D D when it's
actually KSI KSI oh no one cares about
that I know it's so funny dude no yeah
it's not even that I dislike KSI I'm
just talking about in our world Logan
Paul Dylan danis because Dylan danis is
you know part of the MMA community so in
our world it's definitely Dyan danis
Logan Paul you have KSI Tommy Fury and
that's on Doone I I'm surprised they're
still around but yeah they're still
doing the damn
thing I think that card's on at no it
starts at noon Pacific time something
yeah I think uh I posted it
yeah the card starts at noon I think
they walk at like 2 or 3 7:00 p.m. UK so
2: p.m. Eastern here the main card is
set to get underway at 2 p.m. Eastern
so that's 11:00 a.m. here with a main
event scheduled at 6:25 Eastern so
that'd be 3:25 here so you got figure
Logan them probably F at 2 pm here
Pacific Time H that's pretty cool are we
going to do anything or no we
could all right we'll see it's tough
getting the boys rally I know but early
sounds good though everyone has stuff to
do we'll talk to Brian okay if we get
Brian maybe tripley that'd be a fun one
that'd be dope yeah and just do it for
the Main Event co-main Event sounds good
to me like an hourong
companion I'll figure it out we'll try
and make it work my friend suck dud
we'll see Brian like Brian be like oh I
got surf lesson like you don't even surf
I know I met this guy and he was he was
in the Navy man and you should see his
quads and I'm like what the all right is
that it two a couple fan questions is
that cool sure I'll would do like three
so Metal Sonic is asking uh what are you
going to be for Halloween this year
that's a good question all right uh not
the French robot like I should be uh
when I was a kid giving out
croissants
um bosty really wants to be a zombie so
I'll probably be a zombie with him I
assume cool probably be a
zombie nice all right so ww Dash is
asking is it true you gave Dylan's
location when Paul Drive B him drive by
they're talking about when we're at
showtime and Dylan D on the show I'm no
the Paul Brothers they've both been on
the show so they knew our location and I
posted Dylan was coming in and Jake text
me and said hey we might stop
by and I'm not from their world like
that YouTuber to me that doesn't mean
stop by and like cos Mayhem yeah and I
told Dylan I said hey I got a text from
Jake said he might come by and Dylan's
like good hell he goes I'm telling you
man you better get me I want to [__]
that dude up I was like okay so yeah no
I with bad knees or bad knees he had hor
yeah he can even run yeah um and they
came by and they threw water balloons
and Dylan steel tried you know choking
them out wild boys but just that YouTube
world is wild dude those influencers is
wild came by like this
F450 this giant lifted truck at the time
I I wish he would have stopped so I
could peep out that truck but uh no he
didn't get like set up or not nothing
yeah I didn't yeah no Dylan knew that
the there's a chance Jake we didn't know
what he's going to do I didn't know what
he was going to do that's some wild [__]
that was that was a that was a good like
viral moment too yeah all right so if
Georgie's listen definitely post that
yeah Georgie post that uh last one is
from
Chanty is Paula Costa guaranteed a title
shot even after a year layoff if he
beats yes com yep 100% yeah I think so
well there you go is that it that's
all right kids uh Friday I'm off to
Sacramento to Overkill to pick up my
truck we have some sick ass content for
you around the truck and I'm in Niagara
Falls New York November 4th and 5th one
show Friday one show Saturday that's in
Niagara Falls New York and Brett uh
Forte the
most hated comic in Canada the kid he's
a wild boy but uh he's going to be
joining me in Niagara Falls New York I'm
in Chicago December 8th through the 9th
uh bunch of other shows come up so
that's it kids all right but uh Niagara
I will see you November 4th and 5th
Sacramento Overkill I'm coming to get my
truck we have some cool content for you
guys all right be nice each other see
you guys later I'm
out